tout le monde sait ce qu on est d aller
chez le coiffeur de jojo se trouve enfin
sur skate 3 et lui m'a mal regardé juste
avant je propose deux ne rien faire
alors c'est le jeu avec les très bien je
me sens bien les petites figures un
petit peu naze
j'aimerais tellement rentrer dans un mec
au mondial au yoga où est il
il est mort c'est le dcg aucun ce qu'il
peut mais non ouais mais tu aurais pas
fait bouger des fajitas 1 1 voilà ce que
je fais aux gens qui abusent des fajitas
très bien je les passais holbecq taxi
non mais c'est pour abidjan
je ne pouvais plus quitté jusqu'à la
femme de ma vie ah ah bah en fait si par
là y'a quoi voilà battant les mecs mais
les gens se rentrent dedans watts comme
si c'était la passe et repartent en fait
il l'a fait chier lèche la tranquille
dont moi je te défonce en plage tout
roule dessus tu aimes ça inc à
mandailles le mac est enterrée dans le
ciment excusez moi o o b mais là c'est
trop petit nombre d'hommes
je sais juste de faire mon rôle de
super-héros fauna and 11 ans
regardez le il se la pète c'est quoi ça
la figure étoiles de mer patrick bob
l'eponge un skateboard et hop voilà ça
c'est pour draguer voilà avec ma main je
fais coucou aux filles là bas est la
collision sans faire exprès en plus sans
faire exprès la collision oh voilà ça
c'est quand je fais des claquettes
je peux faire ça par exemple sur elle
toi tu vas être dans mon groupe
d'acrosport vaut lui son sac vol le 5 au
8 août dans le sac jaune dans le sac
non non mais make me roule pas dessus
comme et arabes ont bien mais arrêtez là
alors je sais pas s'il a tenté de sauter
dans la voiture comme les gens font pour
entrer dans les voitures en votre stylet
sauf que là y'avait la fenêtre je
cherche un endroit style et non
l'accident nul à dézoner grande
attention c'est la figure ballon ouais
bah nous au québec le ballon le ballon
le mano à mano
je suis là le voit le haut tiens je
télécharger en mode taureaux aux
mondiaux ont fait la course je veux
faire la course pas la position foetale
la course je m'amuse et c'est la
collision
what levêque sauve à l'estec j'étais
rejoint dans sa solitude
oh oui pourquoi c'est toujours moi qui
me les prend mais est-ce qu'on va le
présenter aux excuses auxquelles il
s'est blessé dans l'espace tente otb
paul pour théme et elles peinent à
retrouver votre pc
de rien sitech autant à sa déjà fini
merci le skate c'est vrai que mes coups
il n'avait pas ses prix chers pendant ce
saut à j'aime la terre ok les ventes
comme ça j'avais pas bon non ces gens
piller je pratique opposition fait pas
quand aucune idée de comment ça y est oh
attention nous sommes à shark landes
est ce que quelqu'un voit un requin bien
sûr que non gros sauf que l'histoire ait
connu yeah ah ça va si j'ai le bras sur
le skate je suis content dezeen mouline
away donc toi quand tu te prends un mur
en pleine tête tu trouves tu trouvais
juste bien ne pas jeter retrouver paul
voilà hasard mon vol on s'amuse à jeter
sans attendez yes papa il a tenté et il
s'est dit attends la bonté humaine à 90°
on va arrêter alors qu'alain sol
oh mon dieu notre sculpteur a changé bah
tu me quittes
pourquoi c'est ma coupe de cheveux c'est
l'heure de s'amuser
très bien tentons le slide aux os qu'on
va aller jusqu'au oui regardez regardez
la mauvaise foi au regard des [ __ ]
mais non mais qu eux revient et c'est ce
qui est d'ordre auquel le préfet se voir
lucas regarde et hop
ouais comment ça va la montagne ah ah ah
ces cas là je veux plus de ces cheveux
depuis qu'il a des cheveux je n'arrive
plus
coop a sauvé à me l'acheter carrément
parti dans un autre jeu quand je passais
de skate de skate 3 à crach brody qu
est-ce qu on tente le nom au haut en
presque voilà finir le cul sur le skate
2003 lac date
non c'est ça brûle toi la tête contre le
sol la falaise au revoir skateboard je
t'enverrai des roues oui oui oui oui
j'en ai je ne veuille techniques j2ee
technique
oh oh [ __ ] mais je vais tac tac je
m'en fous mais non non non je te ferai
pas de high five tu as
il hésite et l'homme qui faisait aucune
figure et kiko à la rentrée une écarté
grand les doigts yep savard bord moi ça
va poser aller plus haut
bombay avec sa planche il n'y a rien de
mieux et c'est le show aux boîtes à en
jeu je le caucus et des mois on traverse
au passage piéton [ __ ] au les skateurs
font les fous les gens font les fous ça
lui porte et ça va alors tu te moques de
moi mais tu m'as un k-way une capuche en
plein soleil au total hockey pardon
j'adore le cas oui je viens d'acheter
jeta sur un rôle ou [ __ ] le oh [ __ ]
il était mal j tu veux que tu apprennes
à faire du skateboard regarde regarde
comme on apprend bien faire du
skateboard ensemble vous allez tous
vocale mais voilà et voilà les gens
c'est déjà la fin de cette petite vidéo
sur ce t3 j'ai vraiment envie d'en faire
une de putanges j'espère que ça vous a
plu
on se retrouve bientôt dans une nouvelle
vidéo tient tout le monde
slash major bio qu'on devine il ya plus
en plus de personnes qui prouve qu'il
s'agit du bail c'est l'heure des
excursions premièrement les jours ya pas
mal de personnes qui pensent que pour
trouver des jeux comme ça qu'ils mangent
et la ferons la bière chaude